We got a whole store, about over 400 organic products,...
...ranging from spices, herbs, nuts, grains, sugar, flours,...
...dehydrated vegetables.
We have tea, a lot of snacks,....
...package-free pasta.
We got soba noodles, we've got udon noodles, spaghetti, rotini.
We also have a bunch of liquid goods.
We've got oils and vinegars, kombucha,...
...also superfoods, adaptogens, mushroom powders.
We also have some bath and body products:...
...body scrubs, shampoo, conditioner.
We have a little retail section in here too,...
...with reusables and zero-waste alternatives...
...to your everyday household goods.
Everything is plastic-free.
The store is about 95% organic, non-GMO,...
...and we try to source as locally as possible,...
...but sometimes that isn't always possible,...
...but whenever we can.
We're still competitive with the packaged alternative.
It often ends up being so much cheaper...
...because you're not paying for the packaging...
...and the advertising and branding that goes with that packaging.